- But you know a daughter
takes care of you
and I've got a boy and two girls.
And that one that would drive out of...
Get away from her classes and
a test and come and help me.
I mean she's called me three
times today to check on me.
- Oh wow.
- Oh.
- Oh yeah, girls take care
of their mom and daddy.
Boys go off with their
wife and her people.
- But people that's okay.
- And her people.
- That's okay.
(audience laughs)
- That's gonna be my problem.
(audience claps)
I have two boys.
- [Kelly] Oh no.
- Can you help me?
- Yeah.
- Who's gonna take care
of me when I'm old?
- You start praying for those
daughter-in-laws right now.
(audience laughs)
Yes.
- That they're gonna love you.
- They are gonna love you.
- Thank you.
- Look at your teeth.
(audience laughs)
- Okay, you know what?
Invisalign in my thirties,
braces when I was a kid.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- And I gotta go back to
the orthodontist next week.
- I just went to the orthodontist
and I have Invisalign.
I don't wear them on show but
I have to wear 'cause my gap
came back anyway--
- I love your gap, leave it.
- Yeah, leave the gap.
- Here's what.
I have no problem with the gap.
It's like powerful feeling
and it's not that big
it's that food gets stuck and
I will literally be talking
to people and there's like
pepper just like and I'm like.
- But if your gap is big enough
it'll go right through it.
- It'll fall out.
(audience laughs)
- I had Invisalign.
I'm hoping for a gap.
- Oh.
- I'm like trying to get a gap.
- Well, I had Invisalign now
my whole teeth are like back
on the slant that they were
before because I took them
out and at night I have
this vicious like crossbite.
So all the work has been
undone yet I still have--
- That happened to me.
I lost my mouth guard and I'm like,
Yeah, nobody needs this information.
- This is us.
This is just us now.
(audience laughs)
- Nobody needs this.
Yeah, they're like, "Out of time."
I'm like, "I know you're welcome."